mais d'abord comme lors de la première
vague de kovy 19 les transferts de
patients entre régions reprennent deux
malades sont arrivés cet après midi par
avion à tour ils sont originaires de
savoie département français le plus
touché une aide exceptionnelle car les
services tourangeaux sont eux aussi
saturé à l'aéroport on retrouve romain
des piles les deux patients de zones
d'une soixantaine d'années sont arrivés
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de tours peu
avant 16 heures
les deux personnes touchées par le
coronavirus sont plongés dans un coma
artificiel sont intubés sous oxygénation
et ont été admises
il y a moins de sept jours en savoie si
elles ont pu être transporté par les
airs jusqu'à tours c'est parce qu'elles
n'ont plus à être placé en décubitus
ventral quand les infirmiers et
infirmières doivent retourner
régulièrement le patient afin de l'aider
à respirer ce qu'on prend en charge y en
a encore un qui est sous support
cardiaque avec des drogues qui sont là
pour favoriser la pression artérielle
c'est celui qui va prendre en charge ma
collègue sylvie limousin avec le docteur
leïla cambonie et puis moi j'en ai un
qui est un petit peu en surcharge
pondérale qui lui a fait l'étude du
décubitus ventral pendant deux jours le
chu de tours et la nouvelle clinique
tout ranger à la tour nord accueillent
chacun un patient qu'ovide ils répondent
à l'appel d'une région fortement touchée
par le coronavirus la région auvergne
rhône-alpes
ce sont plus de 7000 personnes
hospitalisées à cause du virus 844 dans
les services de réanimation et les
services de soins intensifs ont tout
leur possible pour faire en sorte de
stabiliser les patients il est transféré
plus rapidement possible dans les
services d'aval libéré des places pour
de nouveaux patients voilà c'est une
rotation constante et les efforts des
confrères sont sons sont très importants
à l'heure actuelle la vision qu'on en a
ceux qu'ils ont faim c'est eux qui ont
la meilleure vision de l'or l'état de
leurs services en tout cas au chu de
tours
on monte on monte en termes de capacité
de l'hydre animations qu'ovide au
détriment évidemment des autres types de
ranimation tour n'est pas la seule ville
à accueillir des patients rhônalpins la
rotation nationale en réanimation
concerne d'autres hôpitaux
hier un mal à dépasser d'ouest en est
par les airs il a été accueilli par le
chu du mans